okay babies it's your boy psychobabble
and we're gonna do something a little
different today
what is this ain't no high tech novelist
we're gonna play a little bit of this
game The Witcher you don't need to you
don't need to understand is right here
that's not really an apartment you know
like it's just like you know people were
talking and you know I like it's it's
just it's the same as always you know
okay no this is made of which I look
very out but I'm actually much younger
okay and we know we skipped that up a
lot of stuff because I'm gonna say if
you're here for the story and not for
psychobabble I just it was like just
watch any of the 10 million freaking
less plays on this right it was far like
80 billion Let's Plays on this like so
many that I can't me think okay let's
say okay there's like a freaking pop
over two seconds here we go is a quest
over there apparently caring okay and I
guess I just freaked out a run
uh-huh all right I'm gonna over here and
start a quest I'm not just our animal
quest that's just our animal quest okay
what do you want I want my lost your key
ma'am
oh my god well here's a lot of black out
there empty this hot father battle a man
arrived what right in like tore his own
cuz next I knew there he was coming my
way
huh grabbed me pan the protection see he
just asked Saul polite grin bony birch
bark by chance or even a few cones no
says I you must be right dr. pester folk
at night was such foolery just staring
at me pan like a magpie or a copper
doing throwing in the dark you know I've
got a soft art so I gave it to him huh
fascinating story any chance you're
nearing me oh my god for another road up
to the hut come on only the first
fella left locked the door hopped on his
horse and that were all I saw of him and
me pan tore old black with sorts not
worth much I suppose what I know
what do you want me dearie bring an old
widow what you could never break down
that door myself truth why nothing to go
in any road such a stench what do you
bury girl cut pay baby never taken on a
pan contract fine I'll go in look around
you should wait here just in case
me let me change the active quest to the
pan quest let's see how am I gonna break
into this thing like on through here
No
let's see the best way to get it here
now this is that magic thing sorry I'm
just I'm so bad with the controls
telekinetic blast there we go huh
seven-card thank you very much rotting
flesh huh
that sound I don't have that
hey cats hey what's God once explains
the stench his throat he was garroted
got rotting old scars kind of soldier
might have that bring it out I put this
on pause that ain't nothing
ok ok we're back why can't I
all right let's get oh my god
okay Jays ass [ __ ] his throat he was
good I say this and some old scars I got
major might have but when I got to me so
I'm going to borrow me yesterday quiet
no oh my god can I get like too much
stuff
yeah there's a lot of good stuff in here
what is that documents almost entirely
burned a few pieces still Jack what can
you a bit quiet like I don't know what
that the rap that's the pen huh the
priceless frying pan scrubbed clean
uh yeah Brad bye bye looks like the
mystery man didn't need the pen so much
as the soot off it to make ink write
letters yeah
I made that hell alright let that
alright let that okay I guess that's it
yeah I mean I it's right in here
your frying pan but Moira Black was sort
and I could see myself in this Sun if I
wanted for them user parsed it was the
cert the man needed he scraped it off to
make ink must have had an urgent letter
to write
urgently burned some other documents to
and I'm the other fellow did round up a
few boys and bury him outside the
village deep so the necrophagous don't
dig into her neck off edge and take my
advice don't mention this to the north
guardians hang about
you've earned a token of any time let it
you know any time thank you what I get
apple juice okay hey we did it a frying
pan a speck n span thank you